This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at It Podcasts. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“TWO点百分之”节目。在The Look Back at It播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜欢的作家。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
欢迎在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何您收听播客的地方收听look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不安全、但绝对坦诚的对话，而你是在和一位知其所以然的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就非得这么做。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何您收听播客的地方收听并了解《艰难学步》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。互联网侦探们出动了一大批人，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷情网》。劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何您收听播客的地方收听《深陷情网》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨一些我们二十多岁时经历的重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to this show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, back for another topic as we break down the psychology of our 20s. when we think about our 20s, I think there are four things that we worry about more than anything else. We worry about love, we worry about money, the future, and finally our friendships. Today we're really going to focus in on that final point there and examine the way that our friendships change during this decade and why despite a lot of the fear and our anxiety and our discomfort, it, this experience is totally normal. It's natural and it's going to be okay. Every one of us has had to witness as someone they were once really close to slowly kind of drips away, replies to their
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能来到这里，收听又一期节目，探讨另一个话题，让我们一起来剖析二十多岁的心理。当我们回想自己的二十岁时，我认为有四件事是我们最担心的。我们担心爱情、我们担心金钱、未来，最后还有我们的友谊。今天我们将重点关注最后一点，并探讨我们的友谊在这十年中是如何改变的，以及为什么尽管充满恐惧、焦虑和不安，这种经历完全是正常的。它是自然的，而且一切都会好起来的。我们每个人都曾经历过这样的时刻：曾经非常亲密的人慢慢地淡出了我们的生活，对我们的
messages less and less, finds new friends who are maybe better for them whilst you're, you know, left feeling a little bit discarded, a little bit unmoored, or maybe you are the friend who has moved on and you're coming to terms with the realization that you have outgrown, the people who are once your closest friends. The friendship group has disbanded, your friends just got a new partner. There are so many ways that we see our friendships change. And it's scary because those relationships are really what hold us up during this decade as we slowly kind of separate away from the security of the family unit and we're trying to form our own identity. Having a broad set of friends in those moments to really rely on and call upon is super vital. And it's also
消息回复得越来越少，找到了可能更适合他们的朋友，而你却被留下来，感到有些被抛弃、有些迷茫，或者也许你才是那个向前迈进的朋友，你开始意识到自己已经不再需要那些曾经最亲密的朋友了。朋友圈解散了，你的朋友刚刚有了新伴侣。我们看到友谊发生改变的方式有那么多。这很可怕，因为在我们逐渐脱离家庭的安全港湾、试图形成自己的身份认同的这十年里，正是这些关系在支撑着我们。在那些时刻，拥有一大群可以真正依赖和呼唤的朋友是至关重要的。而且这也是
really vital for our mental health. There's been so many studies that have shown that people who have close friends, close confidence, they're more satisfied with their lives, they're less likely to suffer from depression. They overall just feel happier. And in contrast, people with poor quality friendships or no friends, they are twice as likely to die prematurely. They're Of course, they suffer increased loneliness. So maintaining a really healthy, broad, fulfilling network of friendships is undoubtedly important. And it's not just about the fact that they provide us with comfort and are obviously massive contributors to our health. But friendship is also just one of the greatest joys in life, right?
对我们的心理健康至关重要。有太多的研究表明，拥有亲密朋友、亲密知己的人，对生活的满意度更高，患抑郁症的可能性更小。他们总的来说就是觉得更快乐。相比之下，友谊质量差或没有朋友的人，过早死亡的可能性是前者的两倍。他们当然会遭受更严重的孤独感。因此，保持一个真正健康、广泛、充实的友谊网络无疑是至关重要的。这不仅仅是因为他们能为我们提供慰藉，而且显然是我们健康的重要贡献者。但友谊本身也是生命中最大的快乐之一，对吧？
There are genuinely friends I consider family who know more about me than any partner of mine ever has who make me. who make me laugh, like beyond reason, that connection is so deep that we never want it to fade. In fact, I think we never consider the fact that it might, it will. That is not where our brain naturally goes to the conclusion of the friendship. Because unlike romantic relationships, I think friendships aren't meant to have an expiry date, they aren't meant to go up in flames, there isn't meant to be a breakup. we're not meant to fall out of love with our friends. That is kind of the beauty of platonic intimacy and connection.
确实有些朋友被我视为家人，他们比我的任何伴侣都更了解我，他们让我……让我笑得前仰后合，毫无道理可言。这种连接如此深厚，以至于我们从不希望它褪色。事实上，我认为我们从不觉得它可能会褪色，它也确实会褪色。这不是我们的大脑对友谊结局的自然设想。因为与恋爱关系不同，我认为友谊是不该有保质期的，它们不该轰轰烈烈地毁灭，不该有分手。我们不该对朋友“不再爱”。这就是柏拉图式亲密关系和连接的美妙之处。
It's meant to outlast a lot of other forms of love. So it comes as a shock when we begin to notice our relationships really shifting or drifting apart from people or realizing that we have mutually outgrown each other or just need space. And a lot of the time our instinct is to A, blame ourselves or be, panic. immediately jump to the worst case scenario. What if I lose all my friends and I end up alone? We don't give ourselves the grace or the permission in these moments of transition to understand that some friendships just have a shorter life cycle and our friendscape is naturally going to shift with age and time. And I think that reaction, that entire sequence of events and
它注定要比其他许多形式的爱情更持久。因此，当我们开始注意到我们的关系真正发生转变，与人们渐行渐远，或者意识到我们互相不再需要彼此的成长，或仅仅是需要空间时，我们会感到震惊。很多时候，我们的本能是A，责怪自己，或者B，恐慌。立刻跳到最坏的情况。如果我失去了所有的朋友，最后孤身一人怎么办？在这些转变的时刻，我们没有给自己足够的宽容和许可，去理解有些友谊的生命周期就是比较短，我们的朋友圈会随着年龄和时间的推移而自然发生变化。我认为这种反应，那一整串的事件和
realizations, is what we're really talking about today, along with all of the psychology that I think comes with watching our friendships change in our 20s. We are going to explore the why, including the literal scientific formula for friendship, the types of friendship endings from the fizzle to the replacement or the breakup, how intensity may actually shorten the lifespan of our friendships, and the impact of simply just entering into a new chapter of your life and dealing with some of the loneliness that might come along with that.
认知，正是我们今天要真正讨论的内容，以及我认为伴随着观察我们在二十多岁时友谊变化的所有心理学知识。我们将探讨原因，包括友谊的字面科学公式，友谊终结的类型——从逐渐淡出到被取代或分手，高强度如何实际上缩短了我们友谊的寿命，以及仅仅步入人生新阶段并应对随之而来的一些孤独感的影响。
I think there are a lot of friendship misconceptions that keep us stuck in really, really draining relationships. You know, am I a bad person if I don't want to be friends with this person anymore? Am I toxic because all of my friends have kind of moved away and stopped talking to me? Am I boring? How am I going to adapt to this new reality? There is so much to discuss here, especially since I think it is so universal. It is such an important experience to explore because it is inherently isolating.
我认为有很多关于友谊的误解，让我们陷入那些非常非常消耗精力的关系中。你知道，如果我不想再和这个人做朋友了，我是一个坏人吗？我是不是很毒，因为我所有的朋友都搬走了，不再跟我说话了？我很无聊吗？我将如何适应这个新现实？这里有太多需要讨论的事情，特别是考虑到我认为它是如此普遍。这是一个非常重要的需要探索的经历，因为它本质上是孤立的。
So we don't find ourselves talking about it enough, which is to say in the midst of a massive friendship transition that I'm sure we are all experiencing, I really hope this helps you. I hope that this gives you a sense of guidance. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why our friendships change and why that is. is totally okay. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
因此我们发现自己对它的讨论还不够，也就是说，在我们正经历着我确信我们所有人都在经历的巨大友谊转变之中，我真的希望这能对你有所帮助。我希望这能给你一种指引的感觉。闲话少说，让我们深入探讨友谊为什么会改变以及为什么这是完全正常的背后的心理学。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中。我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
它们主导着健康产业。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”节目。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day But just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack So I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在白天谈论可卡因，但为了让大家知道，我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了，所以我开始看出一条主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。
So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app
所以，谢谢你补全那句话。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeartRadio App上收听look back at it
Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we
Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方 欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学步》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐中，以至于我们
don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid?
没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且那是两个不同信任层面的问题。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我——科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难学步》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你免费的I-Heart Radio App，搜索Learn the Hard Way并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。为了破案，互联网侦探们出动了一大批人。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我想让人们看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·艾斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷情网》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of... served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This past year for me has been a period of like rapid transition.
劳拉，斯科茨戴尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义得以伸张之前，这一切都不会结束...在亚利桑那州服务。请在Iheart radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷情网》播客。过去对我来说这几年是一个快速转变的时期。
And with that, there's been this real shift in who I spend my time with, the friendships I have. And unfortunately, it's required a lot of reflecting on some of the people that I've seen fade away from my life and kind of feeling a little bit like, my friendship circle is unbalanced. The true biggest factors for me, I think, in that change has been firstly seeing a lot of my friends move away from the city where we kind of all grew to knew each other when we were at university. We all went to university at Canberra and I was talking to my boyfriend about this the other day but I think the reason I've been feeling really isolated is because as we like enter into our, I think early in mid-20s in particular, I
随之而来的是，我花时间陪伴的人、我的友谊发生了真正的转变。不幸的是，这需要对一些从我生活中淡出的人进行大量的反思，并且感觉有点像，我的朋友圈失衡了。对我来说，这种改变中真正最大的因素，我认为首先是看到我的许多朋友搬离了我们上大学时一起成长、相识的城市。我们都在堪培拉上大学，前几天我还在跟我男朋友聊这个，但我认为我一直感到孤立的原因是，随着我们进入，特别是我觉得刚进二十多岁和二十多岁中期时，我
A lot of people choose to scatter. A lot of people move away. And of the people that I'm closest to, one now lives in Paris, one lives in London, one lives in Tasmania, which is like a kind of semi-regional island off of Australia. You know, one of them is in Nepal. And everyone just makes the decision that's best for them. They move on with their lives. And that means that each of us is feeling, I think, uniquely very isolated.
很多人选择四处分散。很多人搬走了。在我最亲密的人中，一个现在住在巴黎，一个住在伦敦，一个住在塔斯马尼亚，那是澳大利亚附近的一个半区域性岛屿。你知道，其中一个人在尼泊尔。每个人都做出了对他们来说最好的决定。他们继续着各自的生活。这意味着我们每个人都感到，我认为，独特地非常孤立。
That distance is naturally going to change kind of the dynamic. because you don't have that same proximity and the ease or access to this other person. It requires more of an investment. And if you're not willing to keep that up, you have to be willing to see that friendship fizzle out a little bit, not be what it once was or kind of hope that they return. And it's one of those magical moments where it's kind of right back to normal. So I think that's like the first big change I've seen in my personal life. The second factor has to do not just with specific friendships, but an entire way of socializing.
这种距离自然会改变某种动态。因为你没有了那种相同的邻近性，也没有了接触另一个人的便利或途径。这需要更多的投入。如果你不愿意保持这一点，你必须愿意看着这段友谊慢慢淡出，不再是曾经的模样，或者寄希望于他们归来。而这是一个神奇的时刻，一切就像回到从前一样正常。所以我想这是我在个人生活中看到的第一个大变化。第二个因素不仅与特定的友谊有关，还与一种整个社交方式有关。
The older we get, I think we lose some of our interest in the ways we used to hang out with our friends when we were 18 or 19 or even 20, particularly to do with the drinking culture. I know for me personally that when I was at uni, it was like binge drinking central. Like that was part of how we socialize. That was part of how we spent our, you know, Thursday, Friday, Saturday nights. It is this thing in psychology called bad behavior bonding, where we sometimes find ourselves really attracted and attached to people who are on an equally chaotic and self-destructive path or in that same place as us in that moment.
随着年龄的增长，我认为我们对18、19岁甚至20岁时与朋友聚会的方式失去了一些兴趣，特别是与饮酒文化有关的方面。我知道对我个人而言，当我上大学时，那里就像是暴饮暴食的中心。那种社交方式是我们生活的一部分。那是我们度过周四、周五、周六夜晚的一部分。心理学上有一个词叫“不良行为绑定”，有时我们会发现自己真正被那些处于同样混乱和自我毁灭道路上，或者当时和我们处于同样状态的人所吸引和依恋。
And then we enable each other. But when one person decides it's kind of time to outgrow that, that they've matured past that kind of chapter, it comes at the cost of the friends they made through those behaviors. I think 18-year-old Gemma would be shocked to hear that, you know, I don't go clubbing really anymore. I don't really want to be up to 2 a.m. on a weeknight. I want to be in bed. I want to be watching Seinfeld. My threshold for social interaction, and I think most people's threshold for social interaction, has lowered significantly as I've entered like my mid-20s. Some of that is obviously environmental, but also some of it is just psychological and personal. Like, that's not what I'm really
然后我们互相放任。但当一个人决定是时候超越这一点，当他们已经成熟，超越了那种生活章节时，代价就是失去他们通过那些行为结交的朋友。我想18岁的杰玛听到我不再怎么去夜店了，可能会大吃一惊。我真的不想在工作日的晚上2点还醒着。我想睡觉。我想看《宋飞正传》。随着我进入二十多岁中期，我对社交互动的阈值，我想大多数人对社交互动的阈值，都已经显著降低了。其中一些显然是环境使然，但也有一些纯粹是心理和个人层面的。就像，那已经不是我真正
interested in anymore. And then there's the other factor of the fact that I have met someone that I have a partner now. When we enter into a relationship, the center of our social universe, our emotional universe or solar system, it shifts away from our friendships and towards our partner. And if you're not careful, you kind of fall out of orbit with those around you. you know, you want to spend as much time as possible with this person that you're falling in love with. You want to see them all the time. You want to invite them to everything that you're doing. That can sometimes come at the expense of those platonic relationships that you've maintained for much longer than you've known this person. So I think it's these like two to three parallel
感兴趣的了。然后还有另一个因素，那就是我遇到了某人，我现在有了一个伴侣。当我们进入一段恋爱关系时，我们的社交宇宙中心、我们的情感宇宙或太阳系，就会从我们的友谊转移到我们的伴侣身上。如果你不小心，你就会有点脱离周围人的轨道。你知道，你想花尽可能多的时间陪这个你正在恋爱的人。你想一直看到他们。你想邀请他们参加你正在做的每一件事。这有时会以牺牲那些你维持的时间比认识这个人还要长得多的柏拉图式关系为代价。所以我想正是这大概两到三个并行的
changes that have left me feeling pretty isolated, perhaps feeling like I haven't adapted as quickly to these situations as I could have. However, I also recognize that in our 20s, we are riding what I like to call the friendship roller coaster. The friendship roller coaster is this phenomenon I've noticed whereby we can feel incredibly happy and fulfilled by our friendships, almost overwhelmed with love, you know, one day. And then three days later, you can end up in this total thought spiral about how we have no one, how we're totally alone, how no one wants to spend time with us, as if three days earlier you hadn't been having the best time. You hadn't been feeling totally validated. That is the friendship roller coaster of our 20s. There are a lot of really high highs and a lot of
变化让我感到相当孤立，也许觉得我对这些情况的适应速度没有自己能做到的那么快。然而，我也认识到，在我们二十多岁的年纪，我们正骑着我喜欢称之为的“友谊过山车”。友谊过山车是我注意到的一种现象，即某一天我们可能会对我们的友谊感到无比的快乐和满足，几乎被爱所淹没。然后三天后，你最终会陷入彻底的思想旋涡，觉得自己一无所有，自己完全孤独，没有人想花时间陪自己，就好像三天前你没有度过最美好的时光一样。你本该觉得被完全认可。这就是我们二十多岁的友谊过山车。这里有许多非常高的高潮和许多
really low lows. And normally at those low points, nothing really has changed except our mental state and it goes to show how so much of our experience of feeling isolated or lonely is entirely subjective and it's based on what I think is a very instinctual inherent fear of loneliness that is not always based on the truth. It is a false alarm. That is why we are so fearful of our friendships changing because underneath that fear is a much more primal fear of being alone and so we've become really hypervigilant to any cues, small suggestions that, you know, point to the fact that our relationships are weakening, that people are becoming more distant. Sometimes that is true. As sad as it is, we are naturally going to lose friends. It is unavoidable. And I want to talk about why we see that
非常低的低谷。通常在那些低谷时刻，除了我们的精神状态外，没有什么真的改变了，这表明我们对感到孤立或孤独的体验有多大程度上完全是主观的，它基于我认为是一种非常本能的、固有的对孤独的恐惧，而这种恐惧并不总是基于事实。这是一个假警报。这就是为什么我们如此害怕友谊改变的原因，因为在这种恐惧之下，隐藏着一种更原始的对孤独的恐惧，因此我们对任何暗示我们关系在削弱、人们变得更加疏远的线索、微小的暗示都变得非常高度警惕。有时这是真的。尽管这令人悲伤，但我们自然会失去朋友。这是不可避免的。我想谈谈为什么我们会看到这种情况
so often in our 20s in particular. This decade is a period of transition for all. of us career transition, mental transition, emotional transition, even physical transition as we spoken about as we kind of move, we scatter, we pursue different paths. Everyone is kind of on their own, you know, I know it sounds cheesy, but their own journey in that moment. We are all trying equally as hard as everyone else to just figure out what we want from life and how we can actually do those things. It's interesting because I think although we are all the same age, age, we are all almost at like different life points. We've all hit different milestones. Some of us are still living at home. Some of us have moved in with like partners. We're living abroad. Some of us
特别是在我们的二十多岁。这十年对我们所有人来说都是一个转变的时期。职业转变、精神转变、情感转变，甚至是我们之前谈到过的身体转变，当我们搬家、四处分散、追求不同的道路时。每个人都在经历他们自己的，我知道这听起来很老套，但在那个时刻，他们自己的旅程。我们都在像其他人一样努力地去弄清楚我们对生活的要求以及我们如何才能真正做到这些事情。有趣的是，我认为尽管我们年龄相同，但我们几乎处于不同的生活阶段。我们都达到了不同的里程碑。我们中的一些人仍然住在家里。我们中的一些人已经和伴侣搬到一起住了。我们住在国外。我们中的一些人
are still at uni. We are all at these very different stages. Whereas for the first 18 years of our lives, if someone was our age, we could assume that they were doing a lot of the same things as we were. We were kind of living parallel lives because of the structures of childhood and adolescence. But in our 20s, that all splinters. It's kind of like a life path explosion. It's at this point of, I don't want to say, you know, upheaval, but like significant growth and impact, that we see the relationships around us change as well.
还在上大学。我们都处于这些非常不同的阶段。而在我们人生的前18年里，如果有人和我们同龄，我们可以假设他们在做很多和我们一样的事情。由于童年和青春期的结构，我们过着某种平行生活。但在我们的二十多岁，这一切都分裂了。这有点像人生道路的爆发。正是在这个，我不想说是，你知道，剧变，但却是显著成长和影响的时刻，我们看到周围的关系也发生了变化。
And they will continue to do so for the remainder of our 20s and the remainder of our lives. One of the biggest moments that I think we encounter this is following university or high school. When we are at uni, we spend so much time together. There is just endless opportunities to be around your friends, opportunities to laugh, to have fun, and we are having this very shared experience.
并且在我们的二十多岁和余下的人生中，它们将继续如此。我认为我们遇到这种情况最大的时刻之一是在大学或高中之后。当我们在大学时，我们花很多时间在一起。有无数的机会和你的朋友在一起，有机会欢笑，享受乐趣，我们有着非常共同的经历。
We're working towards the same goal to, you know, graduate at the end of all this. And our friendships at that point are really, really convenient. You are living in the same place, possibly the same town, even sometimes the same building. You're going to the library every day. You are eating together every day, seeing each other as much as you can. And when we no longer have, A, those shared experiences or B, the shared environment, we slowly lose that closeness. And to understand this, we really need to look at the psychological principles underlying friendship.
我们朝着同一个目标努力，即在这一切结束时毕业。而在那个时候，我们的友谊真的非常非常方便。你们住在同一个地方，可能在同一个城镇，有时甚至在同一栋大楼里。你们每天去图书馆。你们每天一起吃饭，尽可能多地见面。当我们不再拥有A那些共同的经历，或者B共同的环境时，我们慢慢失去了那种亲密感。要理解这一点，我们真的需要看看友谊背后的心理学原则。
These researchers back in the 90s, they proposed that there are four key ingredients or factors that can basically predict whether you and someone else will become friends and also whether you'll be able to maintain that friendship. And these like ingredients are proximity, similarity, familiarity and reciprocity. So proximity basically just means physical closeness. How easy is it for you to see this person regularly? They did a study on this at university dorm rooms, and they found that how close people's rooms were to each other actually predicted the likelihood of them becoming friends. A lot of our friendships basically come down to the ease of contact
90年代的这些研究人员提出，有四个关键成分或因素基本上可以预测你和另一个人是否会成为朋友，以及你们是否能够维持这种友谊。这些成分就是邻近性、相似性、熟悉度和互惠性。所以邻近性基本上只意味着物理上的亲近。你定期见到这个人的难易程度如何？他们在大学宿舍里对此做过一项研究，他们发现人们的房间彼此有多近，实际上可以预测他们成为朋友的可能性。我们的许多友谊基本上归结为联系的便利性
and the frequency of contact. Secondly, we have similarity. We're obviously going to like someone more if they share the same interests, hobbies, lifestyle beliefs as us. But this also includes similarity in terms of current and past life experiences or sharing a similar environment. Then we have familiarity that refers to not just how long we've known someone, how close we are with them, but also the depth of the connection.
和联系的频率。其次，我们有相似性。如果一个人和我们有相同的兴趣、爱好、生活方式信念，我们显然会更喜欢他们。但这还包括在当前和过去的生活经历方面的相似性，或者分享相似的环境。然后我们有熟悉度，这不仅指我们认识一个人多久，我们和他们有多亲密，还指连接的深度。
You know, sometimes we think that the people who have known us the longest know us the best. That is not always the case. Sometimes we meet people and there is just this intense, intense spark, this intense platonic chemistry such that we automatically, immediately feel like we have known them our whole lives. Familiarity is basically just close knowledge of another person. And finally, we have reciprocity, which is knowing that what you give someone in terms of your love, in terms of your energy, in terms of your time, is going to be returned, is going to be reciprocated. So those are the most important factors. When we talk about our friendships changing in our 20s,
你知道，有时我们认为认识我们最久的人最了解我们。事实并非总是如此。有时我们遇到某些人，就是有这种强烈、强烈的火花，这种强烈的柏拉图式化学反应，以至于我们自动地、立即觉得我们一辈子都认识他们了。熟悉度基本上只是对另一个人的密切了解。最后，我们有互惠性，这就是知道你在爱、能量、时间方面给予某人的东西，将会得到回报，将会被互惠。所以这些是最重要的因素。当我们谈论我们在二十多岁时友谊的改变时，
nine out of ten times, I would say that change normally comes down to a shift in one of these four conditions. For example, when people move away or they get really busy, they start full-time work, we lose that proximity. It makes it harder to see them. When we lose those shared experiences, like no longer being at university together, we have less to talk about. When we lose that familiarity, we feel like this person no longer knows us. And when we begin to see a friendship as one-sided without that reciprocity we were speaking about,
十有八九，我会说这种改变通常归结为这四个条件之一的转变。例如，当人们搬走或变得非常忙碌，他们开始全职工作，我们失去了那种邻近性。这使得很难见到他们。当我们失去那些共同的经历，比如不再一起上大学时，我们的共同话题就变少了。当我们失去那种熟悉度时，我们觉得这个人不再了解我们。当我们开始看到一段友谊是单方面的，没有我们一直在谈论的那种互惠性时，
this is when it makes us question how much this person really wants us to be in their life. what I often say is that friendships can survive a reduction or a change in one of these conditions, but not too. So for example, it's totally fine if your friend gets really busy at work and can only see you once a fortnight, once a month, as long as you maintain that similarity, familiarity, reciprocity. You make time when you have time and you talk about things that are interesting and you want to see them. But if suddenly you no longer have those shared stories, beliefs, values, interests, and then you also don't see them regularly, that is when the friendship starts to crumble. Or if the friend is not reciprocating your excitement or your investment in seeing them,
这时候就会让我们质疑这个人到底有多想让我们出现在他们的生活里。我经常说的是，友谊可以承受这些条件中一个条件的减少或改变，但不能承受两个。例如，如果你的朋友工作变得很忙，每两周或一个月只能见你一次，这完全没问题，只要你们保持那种相似性、熟悉度、互惠性。你有时间时抽出时间，聊聊有趣的事情，并且你想见他们。但如果突然之间你们不再有那些共同的故事、信念、价值观、兴趣，然后你们也不经常见面，这就是友谊开始瓦解的时候。或者如果朋友没有回报你的兴奋或你想要见他们的投入，
again, we really begin to question the value of the friendship or how much longer it can last. I want to stress this again. I know that that feels really painful, but it's not abnormal. You are not the only one who was either going through these changes themselves, struggling to connect with people you once loved, or watching someone else feel the same way about your friendship. Watching the people around you suddenly almost disappear. Friendships change because people change and sometimes they just don't change in the same direction. That is not a crime. It is not because there is something wrong with you.
同样，我们真的开始质疑友谊的价值或者它还能持续多久。我想再次强调这一点。我知道这感觉很痛，但这并不不正常。你不是唯一一个经历这些变化的人，不是唯一一个在与你曾经爱过的人建立联系时苦苦挣扎的人，也不是唯一一个看着别人对你们的友谊有同感的人。看着周围的人突然几乎消失。友谊会变，因为人会变，有时他们只是没有朝着同一个方向改变。这不是犯罪。不是因为你身上有什么毛病，
or something wrong with them, I think the worst thing we can do in response to that is actually act from a place of anger or rejection. Because you're not actually angry at them, you're just hurt, you're just scared of losing them, you're just scared of change. And your sadness and your panic is in itself and indicated that you love them deeply. So I think when we are in those moments where we are really fearful that we're losing people, feeling like we should push them away, or, you know, sometimes find a replacement. We do just need to pause and approach this very rationally.
或者他们身上有什么毛病，我认为我们对此做出的最糟糕的反应实际上是出于愤怒或拒绝。因为你其实不是在生他们的气，你只是受伤了，你只是害怕失去他们，你只是害怕改变。你的悲伤和恐慌本身就表明你深深地爱着他们。所以我想当我们处于那些真正害怕失去人们的时刻，感觉我们应该把他们推开，或者，有时寻找替代品。我们真的只需要停下来，非常理性地对待这件事。
This is all about a transition. It's all about a journey. And where you are at now with your friends, like we said, it is the friendship roller coaster. It may not be where you end up. There are other factors as well that I think also alter our friendships irreversibly. And that includes really significant events like a big breach of trust, a betrayal, misunderstandings. I think these things differ from what we were talking about before.
这一切都是关于过渡。这一切都是关于旅程。正如我们所说，你现在和朋友们处在哪里，这是友谊的过山车。这可能不是你的终点。还有其他因素，我认为这些因素也会不可逆转地改变我们的友谊。这包括非常重大的事件，比如严重的信任违背、背叛、误解。我认为这些事情与我们之前讨论的不同。
And when we encounter those things, there are four kind of friendship breakups that we most often see. These are the friendship fizzle, the replacement, the one-sided severance, and the breakup. where really drastic measures are required. So I would say if we have a look at our friendships, the mutual and friendships from the past, the mutual fizzle is most common. There are some people we are not meant to be around our entire lives. We are only meant to be with them for a season.
当我们遇到这些事情时，最常出现四种友谊破裂。这些是友谊的逐渐淡出、替代、单方面切断和绝交。这时就需要采取非常极端的措施。所以我想说，如果我们看看我们的友谊，过去共同的和不共同的友谊，共同逐渐淡出是最常见的。有些人注定不会陪伴我们一生。我们注定只能陪他们度过一个季节。
Before it is, you know, time for us to move on. Maybe this person just no longer feels your cup in the same way you were friends at work, now you no longer have that shared topic to discuss. They were your exes friends. The key word though here is mutual. We both kind of understand that we aren't as close as we once were. The context around us has changed.
然后，你知道，就是我们该前进的时候了。也许这个人不再以同样的方式滋养你的心灵了，你们曾在工作中是朋友，现在你们不再有那个共同的主题可以讨论。他们是你前任的朋友。不过这里的关键词是“共同的”。我们都明白，我们不像以前那么亲密了。我们周围的背景已经改变了。
And perhaps it's time to actually just let the other person go. Stop trying to reschedule the plans. Just let it fizzle. Then we have the replacement. This one really hurts. It hurts so much. Sometimes we have this really intense relationship with someone. They're our best friend.
也许是时候真正放手让对方走了。不要再试图重新安排计划了。就让它自然淡出吧。然后我们有了替代者。这个真的很痛。太痛了。有时我们和某人有这种非常深厚的关系。他们是我们最好的朋友。
We do everything together and then slowly they start mentioning some other person more and more. They're spending more time with them. We feel shut out or replaced. Or perhaps, as we were talking about before, they meet someone, they meet a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a partner. Even though we know that we are not entitled to all of their time, a lot of this comes from a very, I think, just, place of jealousy. And it's a jealousy we typically think is reserved for romantic relationships. But when you love someone as deeply as you love this person, another individual's kind of entrance into your relationship or like the equation can feel like a real threat. And it's
我们无所不包地一起做，然后慢慢地他们开始越来越多地提到其他人。他们花更多的时间陪他们。我们觉得被排斥在外或者被取代了。或者也许，正如我们之前讨论的那样，他们遇到了某人，他们遇到了男朋友、女朋友或伴侣。尽管我们知道我们无权要求他们所有的私人时间，但很多这一切都来自于，我认为，一个非常单纯的嫉妒的地方。而且这种嫉妒我们通常认为只属于恋爱关系。但当你像爱这个人一样深深地爱着某人时，另一个人进入你们的关系或像这个等式中一样，会让人觉得是一个真正的威胁。而正是
these friendships, I think there's very, very, very close friendships that keep us quite grounded, that actually form a huge part of our identity and how we see ourselves. So when One person seemingly moves on or stops investing as much or starts investing more in someone else. It can quite honestly leave us feeling really lost, maybe feel like we should be sharing our time around as well. There's also a saying about these intense relationships that really applies here. The flame that burns twice as bright burns out quicker. I see this all the time with those really high-intensity friendships. You're kind of like addicted to them.
这些友谊，我认为是非常非常亲密的友谊，让我们保持相当的脚踏实地，它们实际上构成了我们身份和我们如何看待自己的很大一部分。所以当一个人表面上向前迈进，或者停止投入那么多，或者开始在其他人身上投入更多时。坦白说，这会让我们感到非常迷失，也许会觉得我们也应该分出时间去社交。关于这些深厚的关系，还有一句非常适用的名言。燃烧双倍明亮的火焰熄灭得更快。我一直看到这种情况发生在那些高强度的友谊中。你有点像对它们上瘾了。
you put a lot of pressure on them more than other friendships, you have this really high expectation, this high level of time that you spend with each other and a lot of demands for the other person that I think can rarely be sustained without the occasional break or some very solid boundaries. And I don't think that those relationships, those really intense relationships, can survive very long without one person in that kind of dynamic, choosing to make a change, which is why I think not only do they hurt a lot, but we also see them ending quite frequently. And then we have this one-sided severance where without reason, someone suddenly detaches, doesn't want to talk to you, doesn't want to communicate with you,
你对它们施加了很大的压力，超过了其他友谊，你对它们有非常高的期望，你们花在一起的时间非常多，对另一个人有很多要求，我认为如果没有偶尔的休息或非常坚实的界限，这些要求很少能维持下去。而且我不认为那些关系，那些高强度的关系，在没有这种动态中的一个人选择做出改变的情况下能存活很长时间，这就是为什么我认为它们不仅伤害很大，而且我们也看到它们相当频繁地结束。然后我们有了这种单方面切断，无缘无故地，有人突然疏远了，不想跟你说话，不想跟你沟通，
doesn't really offer you any kind of explanation. That is just, I can understand how devastating that is. I've had that happen to me before. Sometimes people have their reasons. They don't want to share them with you. That's fine. But you're kind of having to go through a friendship breakup all on your own without the closure. We have to go searching for the answers ourselves. I think when a true friendship breakup actually occurs, we kind of both understand why.
真的不给你任何形式的解释。那真的，我能理解那是多么具有毁灭性。我以前也经历过这种情况。有时人们有他们的原因。他们不想跟你分享。没关系。但你有点不得不独自经历友谊的分手，却没有一个句号。我们必须自己去寻找答案。我真的相信友谊的分手比恋爱分手痛得多，
We know what happened. We know our role in it. We know what we need to take accountability for. but when we have these one-sided severances, you really are kind of left in the dark. You're left looking for your own answers. I really do believe that friendship breakups hurt so much more than romantic breakups
因为我们从未料到它们会发生。友谊总是让人觉得那么持久。随着我们年龄的增长，我们很快意识到它们并非如此。去哀悼过去、去思念、去想要联系是没问题的，但认识到就像一段恋爱关系的结束一样，这可能是最好的结果，这也是没问题的。有时我们不仅渐行渐远，而且我们开始意识到并认识到这个人是如何在我们的生活中制造摩擦的，可能没有尊重我们的界限，或者可能发生了某种事件，突然之间你以一种新的眼光看待他们
because we never expect them. Friendships always feel so permanent. And as we get older, we quickly realize that they're not. It is okay to grieve what was to think about them, to want to reach out, but it's also okay to recognize that just like the end of a romantic relationship, this might have been for the best. Sometimes not only do we grow apart, but we begin to kind of realize and recognize how this person has caused friction in our lives, may not have respected our boundaries, or maybe there was some event where suddenly you saw them in a new
因为我们从不期待它们的结束。友谊总是感觉如此持久。随着我们年龄的增长，我们很快意识到并非如此。为逝去的感情悲伤、回想起他们、想要联系他们是可以的，但同样也要认识到，就像一段恋爱关系的结束一样，这也许是最好的结果。有时我们不仅会渐行渐远，而且开始意识到并认识到这个人是如何给我们的生活带来摩擦、可能没有尊重我们的边界，或者可能发生过某件事，让你突然以全新的眼光看待他们
light and you're just shocked that this is actually who they are and you've never seen that before. I actually had someone tell me the other day about a friendship breakup they had with their best friend of eight years and they went on vacation together and throughout this trip, this person slowly realized that her and her friend could not be friends anymore, that when she returned it would have to be over. Her friend was cruel, would yell at her. would ignore her when other people were around, wasn't willing to compromise. That is not a relationship. We should prioritize.
光芒，你会震惊这才是他们真实的为人，而你以前从未见过。我前几天实际上听人说起过她们和八年挚友的分手经历，她们一起去度假，在这趟旅程中，这个人慢慢意识到她和她的朋友再也无法做朋友了，等她回去后一切都得结束。她的朋友很残酷，会冲她大喊大叫，当有其他人在场时会无视她，也不愿妥协。那根本不是一段我们应该优先考虑的关系。
And sometimes we don't see those parts of someone until we see them in a new situation, like a wedding, like an engagement, like a baby is coming or one of you is experiencing like a lot of really great success and the other person is jealous. I guess in those situations it's better to kind of feel lonely than to be a around someone or trust someone who obviously doesn't have your best intentions at heart. And I guess that's one of my main premises or arguments here. Not all friendships are meant to last for a good reason. And our fear of loneliness should not keep us in relationships that do not nurture and build
有时，直到我们在新的情境中看到他们的某些部分，比如婚礼、订婚、宝宝降生，或者你们其中一方经历了很多真正的成功而另一个人却心生嫉妒，我们才会发现这些。我想在这种情况下，感觉孤独总好过和那些显然没对你怀有最大善意的人在一起或信任他们。我想这也是我的主要前提或论点之一。并非所有的友谊注定都能长久，这是有充分理由的。我们对孤独的恐惧不应该把我们困在那些不能滋养、建立我们
us up and make us better people. We should not sacrifice our boundaries or our needs for the sake of company. You can find company anywhere. You can go to the local coffee shop and have a chat with some nice lady in her 60s and there you go bingo-banggo. You have a best friend. When we continue to pour attention and time and energy into these dead-end relationships, we lose out on a lot of other opportunities to meet people who might suit this chapter or season of your life better, even if it takes some time.
并让我们成为更好的人的关系中。我们不应该为了陪伴而牺牲我们的界限或需求。你可以在任何地方找到陪伴。你可以去当地的咖啡店，和某位六十多岁的好心女士聊聊天，就这样，大功告成。你就有了一个最好的朋友。当我们继续向这些死胡同般的关系倾注关注、时间和精力时，我们会失去很多其他机会去结识那些可能更适合你人生的这一篇章或季节的人，尽管这需要一些时间。
the saying that I always come back to again and again and again. It is impossible to keep every single friend you've ever had, especially as you add new relationships, when your life circumstances change, or when you become aware of key differences in your values and characters. It does not make you a bad person to want to move on, but it also doesn't make you a bad person to grieve and still know that that was necessary.
我一遍又一遍、反反复复回想起的那句话。你不可能留住你曾拥有的每一个朋友，特别是当你有了新的关系，当你的生活环境改变时，或者当你意识到你们在价值观和性格上的关键差异时。想要继续前行并不意味着你是个坏人，但悲伤并依然明白这是必要的，同样也不意味着你是个坏人。
So what I really want to discuss next is how to manage your kind of changing friendship landscape. Whether it is you're seeing more of the fizzle or there has been a friendship breakup or people have moved, what are the do's and don'ts of evolving friendships in our 20s. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast,
所以我接下来真正想讨论的是如何管理你不断变化的友谊格局。无论是你看到了更多关系的逐渐淡化，还是经历了一场友谊的破裂，亦或是人们搬走了，我们在二十多岁时发展友谊的做法和禁忌是什么。所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段短暂的广告之后。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目中，
2% I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
“2%”，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真诚地认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。节目名称是TWO%。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here,
你还记得黛安·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以去寻找答案。就在“Look Back At It”播客中。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day,
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的霹雳可卡因。坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊那天的可卡因，
but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
但只是为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back At It”。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核领悟》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我所说的是。特里·方丹，
Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about
瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此全身心地投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于
wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
胜利与失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now.
我希望你们真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《硬核领悟》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《硬核领悟》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in soons, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他谎言中明显的前后矛盾。这就开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There are a few common misconceptions about friendships. that I think make us feel particularly panicked when we notice things changing in our 20s. The first one that I think is perpetrated, especially during this decade, is that we need to have a massive group of friends in order to be happy.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。关于友谊有一些常见的误解，
This personally drives me insane because I have never been someone who has had this one big, jolly group of friends who do everything together. And I personally blame shows like friends. a new girl for this idea that we need this one tight group of people from ages like 10 to 60 or whatever, like for our entire adult life in order to be happy. Or this argument that we can't be equally fulfilled by one-on-one friendships. When we strip it down, what we really need friends for is trust, comfort, love and belonging. And it doesn't matter what form that comes in. And it doesn't matter what form that comes in, it doesn't matter if it's a huge group situation or if it looks different to what we see others doing, you know, in social media or what we see other people doing online
我认为这让我们在注意到20多岁的生活发生变化时感到特别惊慌。我认为其中第一个被灌输的误解，尤其是在这个十年里，就是我们需要拥有一个庞大的朋友圈才能快乐。这 personalmente 让我抓狂，因为我从来都不是那种拥有一个什么都一起做的庞大快乐朋友圈子的人。我个人把这种想法归咎于《老友记》和《杰茜驾到》这样的节目，让我们觉得我们需要这样一个从10岁到60岁左右甚至贯穿我们整个成年生活的小圈子才能快乐。或者这种认为我们无法从一对一的友谊中获得同等满足感的观点。当我们剥离这一切时，我们真正需要朋友的原因是信任、安慰、爱和归属感。无论它以什么形式出现都无所谓。并且无论它以什么形式出现都无所谓，是大型群体的情况，还是看起来与我们在社交媒体上看到的其他人或我们在网上看到其他人所做的事不同，这都无所谓，
or in the movies and the TV shows that we watch. A lot of that is fiction. And I don't think that we should buy into this idea that just because you've never had a big group of girlfriends or a big group of friends that somehow you are lonelier than the rest. The second biggest misconception is that you should continue a friendship because you owe it to them, either due to the length of time that you've known each other or maybe because they have a lot going on in their life. One therapist calls this a sense of emotional servitude because it involves putting effort towards a friendship as if you're paying off a debt or paying off, you know, or paying them this like energy this time without ever getting anything back for you. Like you are
或者在我们观看的电影和电视节目中。其中很多都是虚构的。我不认为我们应该相信这种观点，即仅仅因为你从来没有过一大群女性朋友或一大群朋友，你就以某种方式比其他人更孤独。第二个最大的误解是，你应该继续一段友谊，因为你欠他们的，这要么是因为你们认识的时间长短，要么可能是因为他们的生活正经历很多事情。一位治疗师称之为一种情感奴役感，因为它涉及到对一段友谊付出努力，就像你在还债或者在付出，你知道的，或者向他们付出这种精力、这段时间，而你却从未得到任何回报。就像你在
doing the emotional labor for this other person. And I see this a lot with friends in a situation where one party is really going through something really difficult, but despite that, has no respect for the well-being of the other person, has no appreciation for the other person's boundaries, has no appreciation for what the other person needs. Sometimes that's understandable, right? If you're going through a really hard season in life, you're not always that aware of what other people are doing. Empathy is kind of not something that you can prioritize at that moment. But that does not mean that you are not allowed to set boundaries with this person just because you're afraid of appearing disloyal or you're afraid of upsetting them, right? That relationship when it
为另一个人做着情感劳动。我在很多友谊中都看到了这种情况，其中一方正经历着非常困难的事情，但尽管如此，却完全不尊重另一个人的福祉，不感激另一个人的界限，不感激另一个人需要什么。有时这是可以理解的，对吧？如果你正在经历生活中非常艰难的一段时期，你并不总是那么清楚别人在做什么。同理心在那种时刻并不是你可以优先考虑的事情。但这并不意味着你仅仅因为害怕显得不忠诚或害怕惹他们生气，就不被允许为这个人设定界限，对吧？那种关系当它
gets to that point is actually if you maintain it without setting up proper parameters or limits is going to do a lot more harm than good. It is going to do a lot more harm than good. It is going to to end up hurting both of you. And we see that a lot with people that have also been friends with someone for a really long time. And even though they just have nothing in common anymore, even though this person may drain their energy, may actually make them feel bad about themselves, they stay. Because they don't want to be labeled as someone who leaves. And I think when you hold on too tight to people who don't want to maintain the relationship or who don't appreciate you, you're basically carrying a dead weight that is holding you back from a new season of friendship
发展到那个地步时，实际上，如果你在没有建立适当参数或限制的情况下维持它，将会弊大于利。这将会弊大于利。这最终会伤害到你们双方。我们在那些和某人做了很久朋友的人身上经常看到这一点。尽管他们再也没有任何共同点，尽管这个人可能会消耗他们的精力，甚至让他们对自己的感觉变差，但他们还是留下来了。因为他们不想被贴上抛弃朋友的人的标签。我认为，当你死死抓住那些不想维系这段关系或不感激你的人不放时，你基本上是在背负着一个拖累你的沉重包袱，让你无法迎接新的友谊季节
and a new season of connection for you. The third misconception is that it's too late for you to make new friends, that by our 20s, we should already know the people who will be in our wedding party or be our children's godparents or who will mourn at their funeral. I think that is absolutely incorrect. research has shown that we replace half of our friends every seven years up until old age, which is to say that we are constantly in a state of pruning our friendships, letting go of certain friends, letting them drift,
和属于你的新的连接季节。第三个误解是，你现在结交新朋友已经太晚了，我们在20多岁时就应该已经认识那些将会成为我们的伴郎伴娘、或者成为我们孩子的教父母、或者将在我们的葬礼上哀悼的人。我认为这绝对是错误的。研究表明，直到老年，我们每七年就会更换一半的朋友，也就是说，我们一生中不断处于修剪友谊的状态中，放手某些朋友，让他们顺其自然，
and then subsequently making new ones throughout life. I read an article that put it really, really well that you are not going to be the same person your entire life and you cannot expect other people to be the same version of themselves as well. You have changed so much in the past 10 years, five years, even the last six months. So it makes sense that those around you, those relationships have also shifted with time. Yes, there might be certain friendships that have evolved to align with this new version of you and this new version of themselves. But it's sometimes just not feasible for you to keep up with every.
随后在生活中结交新朋友。我读过一篇文章，里面讲得非常好，你不会在你的一生中一直是同一个人，你也不能期望其他人也是他们自己的同一个版本。你在过去的10年、5年甚至过去6个月里发生了如此大的变化。所以你周围的人、那些关系随着时间发生转变也是合情合理的。是的，可能某些友谊已经进化，以与这个新版本的你和他们自己的这个新版本保持一致。但有时你很难跟上每一个人的步伐，这确实是不切实际的。
single person who has known you since you were a child, who has known you since you were a teenager. There's just not enough time in the week. Like, there genuinely just isn't enough time in the day to maintain connections with everybody. So you need to give yourself, I think, space to make new friendships that might fulfill you more without being scared that you will never find anybody. I kind of want to reiterate that. Do not hold on to these relationships just because you're scared that no one will fill their place or fill that social need in your life. I think that there are so many people that will just show up in your life one day by surprise and change everything, but you do need to leave space for them. And leaving space means the following. Don't adopt the
一个人从小就认识你，从你十几岁起就了解你。一周的时间根本不够用。就像，一天里的时间确实不够和所有人保持联系。所以我觉得，你需要给自己留出空间去结交能给你带来更多满足感的新朋友，而不用害怕再也找不到任何人。我想要重申这一点。不要仅仅因为害怕没有人能填补他们的位置或满足你生活中的这种社交需求，就死死抓着这些关系不放。我认为有很多人某天会突然出现在你的生活里并改变一切，但你确实需要为他们留出空间。留出空间意味着以下几点。不要采取
philosophy that you already have all the friends you need. It may feel true, but you never know. You truly never know how much opening yourself up to that one extra person could really like change everything for you. Also, say yes to things even when they scare you to invitations, to activities, to joining sports clubs, to new hobbies. Take on the philosophy that everyone wants to be your friend. You are magnetic. You attract really good people. Don't isolate yourself by thinking that you can only be friends with one type of person or that the length of time you've been friends with someone is the only factor in your closeness, is the only kind of indicator of compatibility. I think that we buy into that a lot. that just because we've known someone the longest must mean that they are our best friend.
“你已经有了所有需要的朋友”这种人生哲学。这听起来可能很有道理，但你永远不会知道。你真的永远不会知道，向多一个人敞开心扉会在多大程度上彻底改变你的人生。还有，即使有些事会让你感到害怕，也要对各种事物说“好”——比如邀请、活动、加入运动俱乐部、新的爱好。抱着“每个人都想成为你的朋友”的心态。你具有磁场般的吸引力，你会吸引到非常棒的人。不要孤立自己，不要认为自己只能和某一类人做朋友，或者认为和某人相处的时间长短是你和他们亲密程度的唯一因素，更不是衡量契合度的唯一指标。我觉得我们常常深陷这种观念中，认为仅仅因为我们认识某个人最久，就一定意味着他们是我们最好的朋友。
And time and time again we see that that is not true, that compatibility and chemistry and love and platonic intimacy work in really strange and surprising ways. And with that, do not buy into this idea that you are past your friendship prime. Because when you believe that there was a time and a place to make your lifelong friends, you've missed it, you've missed the boat, you're subconsciously going to be less likely to initiate new conversations, new connections, new relationships, because you already feel like you've lost. You already feel like you're behind. I also think it's very important to not respond with fear when we feel our kind of friendship landscape shifting because fear will have you reacting
但一次又一次的事实证明，这并不是真的。契合度、化学反应、爱以及柏拉图式的亲密感，往往以非常奇妙和意想不到的方式运作。不仅如此，不要去相信“你已经过了结交好友的黄金期”这种说法。因为当你认为曾经有一个结交终身好友的时机和地点，而你已经错过了，错失良机时，你在潜意识里就会更不愿意开启新的对话、新的连接、新的关系，因为你已经觉得自己输了，觉得自己落后了。我还认为，当我们感觉到自己的朋友圈子在发生变化时，千万不要用恐惧去回应，因为恐惧会促使你做出
in ways that are irrational and actually counter to your true intentions, which is to foster deep love with those around you to feel like you belong. Perceived rejection can really sting, but just because your relationship has changed doesn't mean that it needs to be completely discarded. I think about my friendships at least a lot of the time in terms of levels. You have your top rung, kind of your right or die friendships. Then those friends that you maybe wished you saw more or you're slightly less close to at the moment. You've got your work friends. You've got your work friends. You've got your acquaintances, who you would very kindly have a chat with in the street and know a little bit about their life, but you're not super close to. And then you have strangers.
不理智的反应，这实际上违背了你的真实意愿——你的真实意愿是与周围的人建立深厚的爱，去寻找归属感。感知到的拒绝确实会让人感到刺痛，但仅仅因为你们的关系变了，并不意味着就需要彻底抛弃这段关系。至少在很多时候，我是用“层级”来看待我的友谊的。你有你的顶层，也就是那种生死之交的朋友。然后是那些你可能希望多见几面，或者目前关系稍微疏远一点的朋友。接着是你的职场朋友。接着你的职场朋友。还有你的泛泛之交，你在街上遇到时会非常亲切地聊上一会儿，对他们的生活了解一点，但并不是超级亲密。再然后就是陌生人了。
Maybe this person, this person that you are thinking about right now, this friend is just sitting at a rung lower than normal. Does that mean that they need to be completely relegated to the strangers category? Probably not. They're just at a different point in their relationship to you, but you should keep the door open for them to come back in, for them to promote themselves back up to top wrong. Obviously, this does not apply to friends who have totally crossed boundaries with you or who have treated you terribly, but just those who have maybe just have different priorities right now. Give them the grace that you would want in that situation. So I actually have a story about this. I have a very, very close friend of mine, possibly my longest friend.
也许这个人，这个你现在脑海里想到的这个人，这个朋友只是比平时降了一个层级。这难道意味着他们必须被彻底打入陌生人类别吗？大概不会。他们只是和你的关系处于不同的阶段，但你应该为他们敞开大门，欢迎他们回来，让他们重新晋升回顶层。显然，这不适用于那些彻底越界或者对你极其恶劣的朋友，而只是针对那些目前可能有着不同优先级的人。请用你希望在那种情况下别人对待你的宽容来对待他们。其实我有一个关于这的故事。我有一个非常非常要好的朋友，可能也是我认识时间最长的朋友。
And we were incredibly close for the first three or four years that we, after we'd met. Like we did everything together. We knew everything about each other's life. And then we went through this period almost randomly without any context of just like complete disconnect. We saw each other rarely. I really did feel like for certain that the friendship was over. It was really upsetting. It weighed really heavily on my mind. But I didn't want to close the door. And I know that she didn't want to either.
在我们刚认识的前三到四年里，我们的关系好得难以置信。就像我们什么都在一起做，彼此生活的方方面面无所不知。然后我们经历了一段时期，几乎是毫无征兆、没有缘由地完全失联了。我们很少见到对方。我当时真的确信这段友谊已经结束了。这真的很让人心烦，也深深地压在我的心头。但我不想关上这扇门，我也知道她同样不想。
And lo and behold, two years on, I think even a little bit longer than that now, like three or four years on, we are back to that same level of closeness, maybe even closer. She is one of the best people in my life. And I think it's because we gave each other permission, maybe even subconsciously, to follow our own paths, that our friendship has allowed to, you know, is allowed to be this strong because we've seen it through moments of tension and moments of change. And we knew that either we would come back to each other or we wouldn't. And we would still be incredibly happy for the other person. Change does not mean death. It does not mean the end. The best kinds of friendships change and evolve despite factors like time and
结果两年过去了，我觉得甚至比那还要更久一点，大概三四年后，我们又恢复到了那种亲密程度，甚至可能比以前更亲密。她是我生命中最优秀的人之一。我想这是因为我们给了彼此许可，也许甚至是潜意识里，去追寻各自的道路，我们的友谊才得以——你知道的——变得如此强大，因为我们一起经历了紧张和变化的时刻。而且我们知道，要么我们会重新回到彼此身边，要么不会，而无论如何我们依然会为对方感到由衷的高兴。变化并不意味着消亡，它不意味着终结。最好的友谊会历经时间和
proximity. Don't panic. I promise the fear you have is temporary. And alongside that, that fear may also motivate you to make new friends. To go out there and, I don't know, actually put yourself in a position that you haven't had to before. Put yourself in a position where friendship isn't as convenient as it once was, but now you have the opportunity to choose, right? Someone once said to me, I was asking this person, he was like, I don't really have many friends. And I was like, why? You know, aren't you lonely? Why don't, why wouldn't you want a million friends?
地域等因素而发生改变并不断演进。不要惊慌。我向你保证，你感到的恐惧只是暂时的。与此同时，这种恐惧也可能会激励你去结交新朋友。去走出去，我不知道，真正让自己置身于一个你以前从未经历过的境地。把自己放在一个友谊不再像过去那样唾手可得，但你现在有机会去做出选择的境地里，对吧？曾经有人对我说过，我当时问这个人，他好像说：“我其实没有几个朋友。”然后我问：“为什么？难道你不觉得孤独吗？为什么不、为什么你不想拥有一百万个朋友呢？”
And he was like, well, the people around you are who you become. And so I think that it's actually worthwhile to be a little bit picky when it comes to that. And maybe if you're at a place where you are quite isolated and you are kind, you know, you're quite lonely. You have seen a lot of friendships change. Instead of viewing it as this like negative, like life ending thing of like, I'm never, going to have what I once had. I'm never going to feel connected or like I belong again. View it as a new beginning. Be like, wow, I get to like, I get to create the life that I want here.
然后他说：“嗯，你身边的人决定了你将成为谁。”所以我觉得，在挑选朋友时稍微挑剔一点其实是值得的。也许如果你正处于一个相当孤立、有点（你知道的）相当孤独的阶段，你已经目睹了许多友谊的改变。与其把它看作是一件像世界末日般的负面事情，觉得“我再也无法拥有曾经拥有的一切了，我再也不会感到有连接感，或者再也不会有归属感了”，不如把它看作是一个新的开始。告诉自己：“哇，我可以在这里创造我想要的生活。”
I get to make the friendships that I would like to make. I get to be surprised by the people who are one day just going to walk in the door and completely change who I am. I think loneliness is just an emotion. It is just a message from our mind telling us what we need. The same way that hunger tells us, you know, that our body needs fuel or thirst tells us that we need hydration. Loneliness and feeling disconnected to people tells you that it's time to reach out. And I guess that's my final tip here. Be honest with your friends that you would like to see them more or you would like to chat more often. I did this the other day with my friend Steph where I was like,
我可以结交我想要结交的朋友。我可以对那些某天会突然走进门并彻底改变我的人感到惊喜。我认为孤独只是一种情绪。它只是我们内心发出的一个信息，告诉我们自己需要什么。就像饥饿告诉我们身体需要能量，或者口渴告诉我们需要补充水分一样。孤独感和与他人失去连接感是在告诉你，是时候去主动联系了。我想这也是我的最后一条建议。对你的朋友诚实一点，告诉他们你希望能多见见他们，或者希望能更频繁地聊天。前几天我和我的朋友斯蒂芬（Steph）就这么做了，我说：
I'm on the friendship roller coaster right now and I'm at a dip. Can we make time to see each other? And of course she said yes, that openness, that vulnerability is vital here. Because often, others in our life don't really know what we're going through. They don't know how we're feeling. They may not have noticed what we have noticed, that we have drifted. So you can choose to say nothing or you can choose to be honest with how you feel in that moment and 90% of the time the people who truly love you want you to be happy and they will respond positively to that and they will make time for you it is just a matter of of reaching out and you know what in case i haven't said it enough times this is not just you i know it's hard change is hard
“我现在正处于友谊的过山车低谷期。我们能抽出时间见个面吗？”当然她答应了，这种坦诚、这种脆弱在这里至关重要。因为通常情况下，我们生活中的其他人并不知道我们正在经历什么。他们不知道我们的感受。他们可能没有注意到我们所注意到的疏离。所以你可以选择什么都不说，也可以选择坦诚表达你此刻的感受，90%的情况下，真正爱你的人都希望你快乐，他们会对之做出积极的回应，并且会为你抽出时间，这只是一个主动联系的问题。你知道吗？万一我还没说够的话，这绝不只是你一个人的感受。我知道这很难，改变很难，
human beings naturally fear change isolation is hard but do not blame yourself or start to internalize what are actually really common transitions here as a sign that there is something wrong with you or that you are undeserving of good long-lasting friendships. You absolutely are. You just may not have found them yet. I always think of this quote and it brings me so much peace in kind of these moments of catastrophizing. You haven't yet met all the people who you will love in this life. And I think that is so beautiful. How magical is it to imagine all of the people who are now strangers one day, being individuals in your life who you won't be able to live without. These people who you will one day meet who will tell you the story of the life they are now living. We are so young. Sometimes
人类天生就会对改变感到恐惧，孤立感也很艰难，但不要责怪自己，也不要把这些实际上非常普遍的转变内化为自身有问题的信号，或者觉得你不配拥有美好的、长久的友谊。你绝对配得上。你可能只是还没遇到他们罢了。每当陷入这种灾难化的时刻时，我总是会想起这句名言，它能给我带来极大的平静：在这个世界上，你还没能遇到所有你将会爱的人。我觉得这句话太美妙了。想象一下，所有现在还是陌生人的人，有朝一日会成为你生活中不可或缺的重要人物，这是一件多么神奇的事情！那些你终将遇到、并向他们诉说着自己当前生活故事的人。我们还那么年轻。有时候
it's so impossible to really appreciate how young we are. It is not the end of the road. There is so much more love to experience. And like we said, there has been so many studies that have shown that Not only is this incredibly common, but a lot of us replace, you know, 50% of our friends, 80% of our friends every seven years. You are just in a transition period right now, along with many, many others, one that you will come out of and you'll be able to look back at and say, I needed that to happen. I needed to see these friendships fade away. I needed to be alone for a while in order to really appreciate how beautiful these new people in my life are. So I really hope that this episode has helped normalize this experience for you. I totally understand the fear.
要真正意识到我们有多年轻，简直是不可能的。这并不是路的尽头。还有那么多的爱等待我们去体验。正如我们所说，有许多研究表明，这不仅极其普遍，而且我们当中有很大一部分人——比如每隔七年，就会更换50%甚至80%的朋友。你现在只是经历了一个过渡期，许多许多人也都正经历着同样的时期。等你走出来之后，你就能回过头来说：“我当时需要经历这一切。我需要看着这些友谊渐渐淡去，我需要孤独一段时间，才能真正体会到我生命中这些新出现的人有多么美好。”所以，我真心希望这一集能帮助你将这种经历视作正常现象。我完全理解那种恐惧。
Please, I feel like I live this fear every day. So it was actually quite comforting to discuss this and to kind of explore. I think some of the reasons behind why we see that happen. I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope it brought you comfort as always. If you feel like there is someone in your life who feels this way, who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to send them the link,
真的，我觉得自己每天都在经历这种恐惧。所以讨论这个话题并探索我们看到这种现象发生背后的一些原因，其实挺让人感到慰藉的。我真心希望你喜欢这一集。希望它能像往常一样给你带来安慰。如果你觉得你生活中有谁也有这种感受、谁需要听听这一集，请随时把链接发给他们，
to share it along, to share the love along. Leave a five-star review if you feel called to do so and make sure you're following so that you know when new episodes come out. If you have an episode suggestion as well, please follow us at that psychology podcast on Instagram. I love hearing from you guys. I love hearing about what your 20s has been like. You guys always have the most amazing suggestions for topics I have never considered before.
分享出去，把爱传递下去。如果你愿意的话，请留下一个五星好评，并确保关注我们，这样你就不会错过新的一集。如果你有什么节目建议，也请在Instagram上关注That Psychology Podcast。我非常喜欢听你们分享。我喜欢听你们讲述你们二十多岁时的经历。你们总是能提出一些我从未考虑过的最棒的选题建议。
So follow us over there. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
所以去那边关注我们吧。像往常一样，我们下周会带着另一集节目回归。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及建立韧性的科学，
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
探讨我们这个奇怪的现代世界。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方都可以收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends,
对1979年来说，那对我是个大日子。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何和我们的朋友、
fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起挺过来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用上收听《Look Back At It》，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
苹果播客，或者你获取播客的任何地方。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《用艰难方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不安全、无法进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得他在做什么的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用艰难方式学习》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。真人真事，品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。